we're going to do some maths in the news
i like to do maths in the news and a
headline caught my eye recently which i
saw which said
science confirms
politics wrecks your ability to do maths
which i think is the best headline ever
fantastic headline whoever wrote that
earned their money that time so
what was this all about
this was a recent study that has
discovered that people's politics
people's preconceived beliefs are
actually affecting their judgment and
they measured this by giving them a
maths problem to try so let's have a
look at what they did
so this study was done by dan karen of
yale university and others and they took
1
11 people and they measured how good
they were at maths
and they measured their politics are
they sort of left-leaning people are
they right-leaning people and the first
thing they did is they gave a group of
them a
neutral question so the question they
gave them was they asked them about a
skin cream they said this is a skin
cream that we're testing that will
reduce your rash and this is the data
that we got they have people who did use
the cream and then there were some
people who did not use the cream and
there were people who there are people
who made the rash better and there are
people for which it made the rash worse
so does the cream make it better or
worse and this is these are the values
that they gave in the question so 223
people here 75 people there 107 and 21.
so the first question was
does it make the rash does the cream
make the rash better or worse have a
quick look at those numbers
you might want to have a quick go at
that yourself i might ask brady i might
just drag him in do you think this is
making the rash better or worse
[Music]
the cream's not helping yeah
so when you look at those numbers your
first instinct might be to see well
you've got more people there that the
the crea the cream actually helped uh so
you might think oh well the cream helps
it's twice as many people it helped
but if you look over here looking at the
people that it made worse you actually
have three times as many making it worse
so this isn't
going to help you really your first
instinct might be
wrong in that case you have to look at
the percentages so if you do look at the
percentages how many people did it cure
223 out of and then how many people were
tested
298
and that's about
75
and if you look at the people who did
not use the cream 107 people were cured
out of 128
this is about 84
so what you've got here is uh the people
who did not use the cream are actually
getting better
than the uh people who did use the cream
so the
the correct conclusion is don't use the
cream right so that's the neutral
question and just for fairness uh they
actually did the same question with the
same numbers but with the opposite
conclusion and what they discovered
is that people who were bad at maths
didn't do very well they didn't get the
right conclusion about 40 percent of
people got the right conclusion which is
probably
partly guesswork people who were good at
maths though could do this extra step
work out the percentages and they would
come to the right conclusion so far more
people
who are good at maths get the right
conclusion does that mean i'm good at
math because i got it right yes
yes
now next they did is they
gave you a controversial question does
gun control reduce crime this is a
controversial topic in the us does gun
control reduce crime
so does banning
concealed handguns
reduce crime and all they did was the
same question again with the same
numbers if you do the same
procedure again you should come to the
right conclusions in this case the
conclusion would be
the ban is better here you go the ba the
ban is actually decreasing crime but
then again for fairness they did the
same question with the opposite
conclusion now this is where the problem
starts the people who are bad at maths
were again very similar to the other
question
not doing very well on it 40 of them
were getting it right getting the right
conclusion again it's because they
didn't have the maths to do it
the people who are good at maths we're
doing it well
unless it went against their
political leanings
so the people who are sort of
right-leaning
and were actually doing worse
on this question that said
banning guns is a good idea and the
people who were left leaning
were doing worse
on the other question that says banning
guns is a good idea
and they were equally guilty of this
people who are going left and right
politically were equally guilty of this
and their score
dropped dramatically from something like
80 percent of them getting it right
dropping way down to 40 percent of them
getting really big difference it shows
that
people's belief
does affect their judgment what they
think might be happening is
if your conclusion kind of reinforces
your preconceived ideas then you stop
looking further
so in this example here you can see the
223 is bigger than 107. and you go oh
that confirms what i already thought and
you stop looking further if it doesn't
confirm what you already thought you go
oh i don't like this i've got to do some
are you sure i don't believe you and you
dig deeper that means you do that extra
step of looking at the probabilities
and then you do the maths that forces
you to do the maths and come to
hopefully come to the right conclusions
this is an important study
for people who need to communicate
science so communicating science to the
general public there are some people who
don't understand science or don't
understand mathematics
but it's not just that that's not the
only problem there are people who do
understand science perfectly well and
who still let their beliefs cloud their
judgments this was a study on the
general public
i hope that trained mathematicians and
trained scientists
know not to fall for something like this
they would do that extra step and even
if they did so
we have this thing called peer review
our working needs to be checked by other
scientists and by the mathematical
community by the scientific community
and there's nothing
a scientist or a mathematician likes
more than correcting someone who is
wrong it's kind of like the internet in
that respect
but for the general public
this is an important
this is an important thing to consider
when we're trying to communicate
our research
i i'm kind of hesitating to do this
video because i'm hesitating mentioning
politics at all
so please don't go crazy in the comments
try and talk about maths maths is lovely
that is nice